welcome to day two of the games
developer conference 2023
it is so wonderful to see so many of you
from
near and far
I've met so many of you already on the
first day so this is great and isn't it
amazing to be in person again to be able
to meet with other Forks to attend talks
and exchange ideas
it's exciting right
so today I have the honor of speaking
and discussing something that is at the
core of game development
and yet it is incredibly exciting
welcome to the Google developer Summit
talk titled built for billions tailored
for games harnessing Google to serve
players
before we get started I want to
acknowledge so many of my colleagues in
Google Cloud who have contributed to the
products and content that I'm about to
present
you know who you are and you all do such
amazing work
I would like to especially thank my
colleague Mark Mendel Tech lead for
developer relations at Google Cloud for
games for his help with this
presentation
I am ishan Sharma senior product manager
in the Google kubernetes engine
we're a team within Google cloud and
we're focused on
um on Google Cloud for games
I'm part of the Google Cloud for games
team and what excites me most about my
work
is building a platform that powers some
of the most successful Global live
service games
in my life before joining Google I had
the opportunity to work at large and
small companies in the fields of cloud
Ai iot and nanotechnology
when I'm not working with my colleagues
to build awesome products you might find
me hiking exploring new cities or
teaching meditation
so over the past few years we have
witnessed games turn into True Life
Services
the proliferation of mobile devices to
nearly 80 percent of the planet means
that today over 3 billion people are
playing video games
this new type of live service games has
now become the norm
all top 10 mobile and PC games last year
were live service games with console not
far behind
we expect nearly half a billion new
players to start playing games in the
next few years
and about half of them
will be playing games on two or more
game platforms
this means that the opportunity is
larger and more complex than ever
for today's top game companies
it's no surprise that live service games
are the focal of the games industry
when successful live service games are
extremely profitable
take Diablo Immortal for example with 30
million players and over a hundred
million within the first couple of
months of launch or fortnite with an
estimated 5 billion in annual revenue in
2021 four years after launch
there is a catch however
this is a very competitive market being
a large games publisher or are having IP
is just isn't enough
the list of top games is fairly
consistent making it difficult for new
games to break into the market
you really have to hit all the marks and
put player experience first
and let's say that you have the right
game
still isn't easy
live service games are complex to build
they're Global by Design catering to a
global audience often developed by
global development teams
the architectures are extremely complex
with hundreds of interconnected
applications
it is complex running a global game and
meeting your players expectations
so what makes life service game
successful
it is in fact something that is critical
to any game
in Live service games player experience
is Paramount
there's so many things that you do to
ensure a great player experience yet
there are three tenets that really stand
out to ensure a great player experience
one a stable network connection that
provides low latency
if your players are suffering from Bad
latency they're going to have Magic
Bullets and rubber banding and generally
a poor experience
a game server that you can rely on
that can ensure uninterrupted game
sessions
it is a terrible feeling when a player
is just about to win a match and the
game server just crashes right before
the match can finish
third
Global availability and scale
today's games are played on a global
stage
your players are everywhere
they can join anytime
and they expect a great experience every
time everywhere
unavailability of Game servers latencies
and matchmaking unanticipated player
traffic patterns slow scale up and
interruptions in gameplay can cause poor
player experience player churn and low
future adoption
preparing for a game launch without
reliable infrastructure to scale with
the game's success can be scary
if any of these don't hit the mark
players churn
and it is extremely difficult sometimes
even impossible to recover from an
unsuccessful Game launch
running your games in the cloud in
Google Cloud for example can help with
all of these needs and more
our robust infrastructure built upon
years and years of experience are
reliable networking Geographic
availability capacity to scale to your
player traffic all help ensure that your
player experience is top-notch
at Google Cloud we are no stranger to
live Services over five of the world's
largest video audio and social platforms
run on Google Cloud including some of
Google's own products that you've
probably heard of like YouTube
we've seen what the shift to live
service models does to Consumer
expectations
consumers expect maximum uptime and
stability
agile and optimized experiences and safe
and inclusive communities
for Industries like games that are
transitioning to this new model it can
be challenging
that's why many of the biggest game
companies in the world have partnered
with Google Cloud to power their live
service games
foreign
we're building an ecosystem for live
games that unifies understanding and
performance
we believe our Solutions work best when
we use together as a cohesive whole
creating something greater than the sum
of its parts
we have identified three key use cases
that are critical for powering the live
service games of today and tomorrow
for each of these use cases we have
cutting-edge solutions that come
together to form a powerful ecosystem
for live service games
we start with Game servers the
technology that brings together players
from all over the world into common
real-time experiences
next up
are the databases that allow games to
manage and store their most critical
data to provide a seamless player
experience
and of course there's analytics which
Google is most famous for allowing game
companies to to deeply understand their
business and players
during this session
we will deep dive into how you can
modernize and augment your game servers
with familiar tools reliability and I.T
expertise all baked in
so let's double click into Game Servers
if you take a step back and we if we
look back to traditional Game Servers
running on premises
we quickly realize that there are
inevitable roadblocks to providing an
exceptional player experience
sure buying a physical server to run a
game isn't that hard
and it will perform great
at first
while you amortize the value of the
investment you will continue to invest
in maintenance and operational costs
over the years eventually the servers
will age out increasing the chances for
failure
this leaves you with running your
players on Old Hardware that's prone to
more failure
but I can solve for that is Sean no
biggie what else you got all right what
about scaling to New Markets where do I
need these servers what if I'm wrong
with my initial estimates
what if I think Indonesia is going to be
big but Brazil sees huge adoption
how fast can I redeploy my servers is it
even worth it when you consider duties
taxes Logistics Etc
what about Colo contracts and purchase
networking but let's say you can fix all
that
it's still going to take time and during
that time you run the risk of losing Big
Spenders
finally the talent poor pool today is
more and more picky Engineers want to
leverage best practices operate with
newer Technologies do their own
innovation
and what happens if you're fully reliant
on a process or script
written by someone who wins a lottery or
goes to greener pastures what do you do
then
you begin your quest your quest for a
magical platform
what if
I told you today there was a platform
that is fully managed
is highly available
automatically scales your workloads both
up and down
provides an SLA on your workloads
only charges for the resources that you
consume
and is powered by open source technology
Google kubernetes engine gke is your
answer
gke is the platform of choice for
running modern containerized workloads
Google kubernetes engine is the fully
managed
most automated and scalable managed
kubernetes platform run by the largest
contributor to kubernetes Google Cloud
sounds too good to be true
let's dive Draper into the key valid
propositions of gke
gke is fully managed
Google cloud is the first and only
provider
with an entirely managed kubernetes
platform gke autopilot you can spin up
production Glade clusters in minutes
with the click of a button or a single
API call
this comes with fully managed cluster
lifecycle management including upgrades
and backup or restore
this unmatched Simplicity and automation
allows you to focus on business
imperatives and not the infrastructure
gke is secured by Design
with production grade security controls
and policies right out of the box
our hardened configuration locks down
clusters and prevents unwanted access by
default
and automatic security patches patch
security vulnerabilities with no action
required from you
gke is workload optimized our industry
first four-way Auto scaling dynamically
scales workloads to meet business
demands you can seamlessly scale out to
thousands of clusters or scale up to 15
000 nodes per cluster
furthermore built-in cost optimization
insights help you analyze the cost and
performance of your workloads
gke offers proven reliability
with the entire open source kubernetes
project built tested and distributed on
the Google Cloud platform
who better to run kubernetes than the
largest engineering contributor to
kubernetes
your workloads run on the same
infrastructure which serves billions of
requests per day
sounds great doesn't it
but wait a minute
for running game servers we have a few
key requirements don't we
we need the ability to start and shut
down Game Servers on demand
we need to be able to predict games or
to protect Game servers that are running
with players on them
these allocated Game servers that are
running game sessions cannot be shut
down
even if there are upgrades that are
coming up
also we need to be able to Scale based
on demand such as location number of
players Etc rather than CPU utilization
the challenge is that kubernetes on its
own doesn't understand Game Servers
it was designed for stateless
applications but for Game servers by
definition state is critical
so in 2017 in a partnership between
Google and Ubisoft we built agonis which
treats which teaches kubernetes
how to run game servers
since then we have worked with
contributors across Google and many
studios to build and enhance agonis
agonis understands
game sessions scales with player load
supports multiple ports per node and has
tunable warm-up parameters
and running agonis on gke enables
hosting running and scaling dedicated
Game Servers
on the right you will see a
representation of how agonis manages
fleets of dedicated Game Servers via
nagonist controller all running on
kubernetes in this case gke
running agonis on gke brings several
benefits
you can pack servers and reduce waste
easily deploy Game servers in the right
places at the right time
be engine agnostic whether it is Unity
unreal or your custom engine
track the health of your fleets with
integrated logging let your staff
innovate with kubernetes
technology that your staff likely is
already familiar with
sounds amazing doesn't it
but we're obsessed with innovating for
our customers so we did not stop there
we wanted to make it even better
so starting today you can run your
Global multiplayer game servers using
the fully managed GK autopilot for a
truly automated hands-off experience
for players games just have to work
therefore you the game developers must
have underlying Cloud infrastructure
that is simple to operate and seamlessly
scales with player traffic
so that you can focus on what truly
matters building great gains
at Google Cloud we're fixated on making
game launches boring by making GK
autopilot the platform of choice for
running game workloads for scalability
reliability and automation
with GK autopilot for game server
workloads we are bringing the best of
managed kubernetes to games
in GK autopilot Google manages your
cluster configuration including your
nodes scaling security and other
pre-configured settings
autopilot clusters are optimized for
production workloads and provision
compute resources based on your
kubernetes manifests
therefore by relying on defaults
codifying best practices delivering
enhanced slos and built-in automation
autopilot provides the most complete
scalable and fully automated managed
kubernetes experience
but what does this mean to you
faster time to Market
through GK autopilot we've made it easy
to build on kubernetes even without the
need to be an expert
furthermore through GK autopilot we help
you reduce the overhead associated with
day two operations so that you can
dedicate fewer resources on managing
kubernetes clusters
according to a recent Forester study
customers developing on GK autopilot see
a 45 45 Improvement in developer
productivity
for you this means that you can focus
Less on building and managing the
infrastructure and focus more on what
truly matters
building awesome games
second is always on reliability
GK autopilot is the only full kubernetes
service that offers a workload level SLA
backed by Google SRE
it can automatically reliably handle
provisioning and scaling operations both
up and down based on workload
requirements
furthermore better mean time to respond
and fewer support ticket saves you time
and effort on your cluster experience
you also get the flexibility to defer
management and maintenance in release
channels
for you this means that you can launch
your games with confidence knowing that
your game will reliably scale with
player traffic
secure by default
in GK autopilot by relying on defaults
and codifying best practices we minimize
the attack surface through defense
in-depth approach
Harding cluster configurations lockdown
nodes workload identity support for ASM
config sync policy controller all of
these results in fewer vulnerabilities
and exposures on autopilot clusters
finally cost optimized
you pay only for the game server pods
talk about this a little later but has
automated efficiency pod pricing and
maximized utilization which helps in
reducing optimize which helps in
reducing operational cost
according to the Forester study up to 85
reduction in operational cost was
observed by running on gke autopilot
so running your game workloads on GK
autopilot offers you full control full
freedom and impeccable integration
but fully managed doesn't mean
vendor lock-in
some game companies on Google Cloud run
their game clusters on fleets and span
across regions on premises or on other
Cloud providers since Adonis is open
source and GK autopilot is based on
kubernetes which is open source when
serving your games with GK autopilot you
don't have to sacrifice portability or
flexibility
better yet
Google Cloud continues to be the largest
contributor to both agonis and
kubernetes projects allowing you to
leverage our expertise and help Define
the roadmap to serve the next generation
of games
by running on GK autopilot you will
enjoy the benefits of fully managed
however you know this better than anyone
the technology needed for successfully
running Global Multi-Care player games
extends Beyond dedicated Game servers
and includes matchmaking Services custom
Network proxies databases and Analytics
when running game servers on GK
autopilot these Integrations are easy
for example you can use openmatch on GK
autopilot to run Matchmaker with your
dedicated Game servers or manage player
data with Cloud spanner
you know what I can speak all day about
the benefits of running game servers on
autopilot but there's nothing like
hearing from one of our customers
very recently our customer DNA tested
out game servers on GK autopilot and
they had positive reviews
they shared GK autopilot is helping us
scale our game servers and our team
without scaling our costs
it is always heartwarming to see that
our products are making a difference for
our customers
now comes the part that I'm really
excited about and I imagine a lot of you
are waiting for
at Google Cloud we're obsessed with
powering everlasting love for your game
and we love games
so we built a global scale game demo
what can be better than testing out our
own technology for a real world global
global scale multiplayer game
we wanted to build something that is
educational a large scale demo with
multiple integrated Google Cloud
products it is built on Unreal Engine 5
uses GK autopilot for dedicated Game
servers and game back-end microservices
it uses open match for matchmaking
Cloud spanner for player in-game data
Cloud deploy for continuous delivery and
antha service mesh for multi-region
allocation
on the on the right side you will see a
gameplay screenshot from our Global game
demo
so here's the architecture diagram
starting with player clients on the left
we have clusters in multiple Google
Cloud regions though here I've only
shown U.S Central 1 and Europe West one
on this image
the front end runs on gke
more on that later
feeding into the profile service and the
open Match components profile service
connects to globally replicated Cloud
spanner and the match director connects
via antha service mesh to agonis
allocator Services running on Regional
gke autopilot agonis clusters
of course Agonist Game servers are
running on GK autopilot as well
so let's explore some user Journeys
as a game developer I want to run and
automatically scale my dedicated game
server fleets on the cloud
GK Game servers and Game servers and gke
autopilot is the answer it is easy
create a GK autopilot cluster with
create Dash Auto install agonis
and run this yaml
by using a gonis Fleet auto scaler with
GK autopilot your Global game server
the entire fleet can scale automatically
and dynamically as players flow in and
out of your games
basically you can set it and forget it
as we see in the cartoon illustration
below with traditional kubernetes this
scaling requires resources and time for
planning right sizing bin packing you
might over provision node pools much
earlier in anticipation of scale up and
keep those node pools running longer
before scaling down all of this costs
money
the cartoon in traditional kubernetes
you have to pay for unused capacity you
have to pay for Game Servers
kubernetes system the OS all of that
but with autopilot you pay for Game
servers only you pay for the pods
scaling Game servers with GK autopilot
just makes sense
because Game servers are pods and
autopilot's autopilot speaks in units of
pods
so autopilot ensures you pay only for
your running game server pods and you
don't pay for system components
operating system overhead or unallocated
capacity
it's a pretty sweet deal
as a game developer this is an xuj as a
game developer I want to run back-end
game services to support my dedicated
Game Servers
now my colleague Mark Mandel will walk
you through how we can run the backend
services in our game
so let's take a look at the autopilot
cluster that we set up to handle all our
gain back-end services this is actually
really nice to have during development
because at no point during the
development process did we have to worry
about the size of our kubernetes cluster
we just deployed stuff to it and
autopilot took care of the rest which
was actually really nice we could just
kind of deploy whatever we needed and
autopilot was just like cool I got you
which is pretty awesome so let me take
you through each of the services and
just kind of highlight a few of the
interesting qualities of each of them so
you can have a sense of the stuff that
we do
so uh the first thing that uh the game
client is going to talk to is our
front-end service all communication goes
through the front end if I actually
click through on the console here you
can actually see yep that's the only
public address you're going to see
throughout the project all information
goes through here everything else is
internal so front end handles
authentication uh people log in using
their Google oauth and then all
Communications were sent through are
checked against that authentication
token that you've received so front end
once they've connected to the front end
the next thing they're going to talk to
is the profile service this is our
service that talks to our spanner
database it basically its job is to
store profile data and any other in-game
data that we want to have attached to
that profile just to prove to you that
it is a private service you can see here
it's not exposed publicly we don't allow
that
but yeah that's that's pretty much it
it's a pretty simple rest web service
but it's important that you know that
profile information is able to scale so
spanner is a winner there now the next
fun thing that happens is we actually
have this ping Discovery service that
the front end talks to the job of that
is actually to introspect the project
and look to see what Ping endpoints that
are Gunners usually spins up that it can
then tell clients hey there's a latency
ping endpoint in this region there's one
in this region there's one another
region uh and the way the Ping Discovery
service does that is actually looking at
the front end rules for basically the uh
within the Google Cloud project collates
them all and hands them over to the
front end to hand back over to the
client so it can basically be like
here's a here's an IP that I can send
you to be packet to and it's going to
send that back I want to show you one
cool thing that I think is actually kind
of nice if I actually look down at the
Pod
um we have a look at it's yaml you will
notice there's this service account that
is right here
um now what is nice is we're actually
using workload identity to be able to
give this pod the access control it
needs to be able to query Google Cloud
rest apis and be able to pull out this
information so we create a service
account that matches to this inside the
kubernetes cluster we tied that to a
service account that lives inside Google
cloud and that service account that
lives inside Google cloud has the
appropriate permissions to be able to
query forwarding rules which otherwise
it wouldn't be able to do so workplace
identity is great because you don't have
to export any service Keys We handle all
that transport for you so you don't have
to worry about that where to store them
what to do with them anything like that
so I think that's actually kind of neat
so ping Discovery will turn a list of
regions plus the locations for those
latency measurement Services ping
Services essentially so that they can
take that information the client can
query all those grab all the latency
information for all the regions where we
have Game Servers
and then send that all up to the front
end which is going to send that all into
our Matchmaker open Match now I'm not
going to go through all of these these
are all the components that exist within
openmatch but there are two that are
custom
so first of all we have this match
function basically a grpc service what
its job is is to say how many players
have I got in my match queue I've got
three cool let's look to make sure that
uh those three are close by to each
other if they are based on that latency
information we sent put them together
send them to a game good
lastly let's talk about the open match
director the director's job is to do the
integration between open Match once it
has that group of players to play a game
and sending out that information to a
guys to say hey I need a game server
from this particular region because I
need to have players who want to play
again
now each individual cluster has what's
called an allocation service it's a rest
API that says give me a game server and
Market is allocated which we'll talk
about in another demo
what's cool about what we're doing in
here is
we need a way to communicate across
clusters in a way that's kind of easy
so here we're using anthos service mesh
so antho service mesh means that we can
have communications via VIA DNS entry
basically local to this cluster that can
go multi-cluster now once that's set up
across all the Clusters that need it for
any pod that needs to either communicate
out to multiple clusters or receive
information across multiple clusters to
simple as adding this label here
once we've done that this director can
now be like hey on this DNS entry go ask
me for an allocation
and then ASM and istio behind the scenes
do all the work to make sure that that
communication happens cross-cluster
honestly I don't even know what happens
it's kind of cool I just throw the label
on and I'm good to go which makes me
very very happy
cool so that pretty much gives you an
overview of all the major components
that are in our backend services like I
said it all runs on autopilot using
anthos service mesh as well as well as
an integration with a spanner database
and it's been really great everything's
been running really smoothly and we
haven't really had to worry about any of
the infrastructure needs of our
kubernetes cluster autopilot takes care
of it for us awesome
back to you ishan
thank you Mark
so let's jump into our next user Journey
as a game developer I want my Global
Matchmaker to allocate and send player
traffic to a dedicated game server on
any of my globally distributed clusters
so Mark mentioned a bit of this uh just
now so here we use anthra service mesh
ASM is installed and configured across
all agonis clusters and the game
Services cluster this allows class cross
cluster communication between services
in the mesh
to add a service to the mesh a sidecar
container can be injected into any pod
containing the ASM managed label
see that with the little arrow pointing
the mesh is used to establish
communication between the open match
director and the agonis allocator
the mesh is configured to Route requests
to the regional agonis allocator
endpoints based on request header from
the openmatch director
to make a client request from the global
game Services gke cluster to one of the
regional endpoints essentially apply the
ASM managed label to the Pod shown on
the top of the right side of the screen
you go to the bottom you can make a
request with the regional header from
the openmatch director on the global
game Services GK cluster
in this case
Asia East one
next use a journey as a game developer I
want to deploy my game server updates to
clusters region by region
so here we do it using Cloud deploy
Cloud deploys new multi-target
deployment capability enables you
to to uh to to provide continuous
delivery for gke you create GK clusters
in the regions where your players are
closest to
group them as targets into multi-targets
and then deploy your agonis game servers
in waves
first to validate in a staging
environment you can create a staging
Target at the start of your progression
sequence and we'll show you that in just
a second
you need an approval pause button before
deployment to production you can also do
that cloud deploy supports along with
multi-target rollback exactly that
feature so now back to Mark to
demonstrate that in action
so here we have our Cloud deploy
pipeline for our Global deployment of
our game servers we've set this up so we
can sequentially deploy from Asia to
Europe to U.S Central because that's the
order we want to be able to test in
based on population size and some other
things that we like to be able to test
with
now each of these Cloud deploy targets
we have here
actually are backed by multiple
kubernetes clusters this is the new
multi-target Cloud deploy feature
so if we dig into Asia East for example
and look at its child targets we can see
that actually two kubernetes engine
clusters behind it one of these actually
happens to be GK standard and one of
these also happens to be a gke autopilot
it doesn't actually matter it all just
works the same so both of these have a
gun is installed and they're ready for
Game servers we just need to send our
game servers out to it and deploy it so
let's come back to our view here you
could be doing this through some kind of
git office operation or maybe something
tied to Cloud builds for example which
we do in our example but I'm just going
to do
um a manual deploy here with the details
that I know already exist I'm not going
to go too far into the details of what's
Happening Here but what I'm going to do
is basically say here is my
configuration file for how I want my
deploy to occur it's going to deploy and
I've gone as Fleet that's a group of
Game servers and you can see in that
really long image line there I'm
actually going to specify that this is
the particular image that I'm going to
push up like I said before usually this
would be part of an entire build process
but for demonstrative purposes I'm just
going to throw it up here directly
now the Rolex here has started we can
see that it is queued down here we give
it a minute it will kick through okay
here goes our release zero one in
progress and rolling out to both
clusters at the same time in our Asia
east region this means we can set up
pipelines where we can Target regions or
really any grouping at all irrespective
of how many gke clusters we have behind
them this is a really nice abstraction
for being able to deploy across multiple
regions or across multiple gke clusters
without having to worry about how many
clusters there are behind it awesome so
this is now deployed to Asia East uh if
we wanted to we could then launch in
that region but we don't have anything
yet in Europe West and U.S Central one
so assuming everything has gone
perfectly in Asia East one and of course
it has we can now promote it to our next
stage
if you do this here through the gcloud
commands we can do it through apis uh
we're just going to do it through the
console for now so we're going to
promote uh zero one to the next stage it
currently doesn't have a stage yet
roll that out into the next region
now stages can be anything here I've
just done stages on a per region basis
you could do Dev stage prod you could do
really anything at this point but I
think it fits really nicely into that
Paradigm of hey I want to send out game
servers and I can do it in a region by
region basis this also means that if
anything fails I can also roll it back
too wonderful that all went ahead I'm
gonna promote it up to us Central as
well
promote
yes I do want to promote the release to
us Central
and very shortly now I will have a
global Fleet of Game servers running
across six agonized clusters
um that I can now tap into which is
pretty cool and I can do this in
multiple times so next time I have a new
version I can roll it out to Asia East
test it there when they wake up assuming
that all goes according to plan I can
move it to your quest and so on and so
forth if it doesn't go to plan I can
back it out try again maybe then I don't
have to deploy it to a much larger
population base for example
um I can test it out in particular
region see how I go there's lots of
things I can do here awesome so that
seems to have deployed everywhere
successfully what I'm actually going to
do now is I'm going to pop over to the
object browser that we have
kubernetes engine console which is
actually super super handy and I'm going
to refresh this View and I have it
filtered already to the Clusters that
run a gun is uh and the igonest.dev
group and so we can actually see our
fleets we can see that we have
successful fleets installed at each
cluster in Asia East each cluster in
Europe West each cluster in U.S Central
the other nice thing is we can actually
dig into his as well we'll have a quick
look at one of them and we scroll all
the way down and we can see that we have
three ready replicas that means we have
three Game servers which is what we're
asking for in each cluster ready I'm
waiting for players so our Cloud deploy
scripts work we now have a global game
server Fleet and we can play a game in
just a minute back to you ishan
thank you Mark
what I love particularly about this demo
is the visualizations because it gives a
feeling of accomplishment as you can as
you go through each stage
I particularly enjoy that
moving on to the next user Journey
as a game developer I want player
actions to be secure and consistent on a
viral game
that can scale globally
the solution Cloud spanner
for a new game it is the choice for a
game's back-end database it is our
battle tested game critical database
that is highly responsive and elastic
for viral game workloads it provides
unlimited scale Global consistency
across regions and high availability
up to five nines
built in SQL it is easier to find
talented Developers for them to get up
to speed on a code base and for you to
optimize your database backend spanner
can scale up and down without taking an
outage
you can align capacity to the size of
your player base without worrying about
negatively impacting your players
experience the same is true for patches
security updates
Etc
it's Global by Nature reliable by Design
and spanner makes it easier to put your
players first and ensure a positive
gamer experience
here we show you a sample schema of what
the world scale demo has uh while using
spanner
enough of all of those user Journeys I
think the most important user Journey
is I just want to play an actual game
so let's do that
here is a demo
of the game in action
over to mark
so let's show a quick demo of us running
this Global skill game
start let us run in Savannah launcher a
launcher here does all our
authentication for us as you can see it
has my my name here already so I'm I'm
already authenticated which is super
nice
um and it looks like a game launcher
just like everything else
what it has is because we're running you
know we're going to run a multiplayer
game Let's actually it gives us the
ability of running multiple instances
which is nice
uh and it's going to create our game for
my launcher much like if you had a
Launcher for any other game
so let's create three instances
do that real quick boom one two one two
three beautiful so we can have three
people playing this game uh as you can
see the authentication has gone through
to our front end service so we get our
name on all our clients here as well so
that's all authenticated against our
profile that is stored behind the back
end
um and we're gonna click play an online
match to connect to our front end which
is authenticated which will then connect
to our open Match instance which is
waiting for our three players to All
Connect and is going to match them into
a game while looking at latency
information and connecting us to a game
server that is closest to us
all right and that's all worked so we've
got the three players here and I'm in
the top right hand corner you can see me
there
I'm just uh
I'm gonna shoot in some stuff I'm gonna
fly around a little so you can see me
moving in some of the other screens and
you see me playing this game game runs
for about 30 seconds uh I'm winning
because there are no other players other
than me and I am awesome
um but you can see we're playing in our
unreal game it's connected to our game
server that is running on our kubernetes
cluster that is probably running on one
of the US ones because that is closest
and the game is now finished
um I won because I'm amazing
um but now this will actually shut down
the game server that we were playing on
and allow it so that there is a new game
server for those other players to play a
game
so let's just quit this really quickly
um as you can see that all worked and
we'll go back in time a little bit and
have a look at those game servers in
action
if we pop up in our terminal here have a
look at the cluster that we were
connecting to
we can actually see things in action as
the game is being played
so we're going to do a watch on the game
servers that are currently running on
this cluster
when we set this up we set up three Game
servers here you can see they're all
ready and available and waiting for
players
and when the game server session spins
up what we'll actually see is one of
those moved to allocated if you haven't
used a gun is before allocated is the
very special state that basically says
hey this game server has players on it
so please don't delete it we just want
to let our players play their game
so as you remember the game was about 30
seconds long and since we're playing
with time let's speed that up a little
bit and we'll see that when the game
server is finished with the game that 30
seconds is over a game server shuts down
which you just did there we just saw it
happen and it goes away
that's how the game's over set up and a
new one immediately replaces it and very
shortly we'll move into a ready State
there it goes and it is ready for more
players to play a game now in this
particular instance what we've done is
actually just had a static set of Game
servers we've got three here you could
have 10 or 100. we could Auto scale this
as well and we probably will do in
future improvements to the project but
this gives you a sense of how these game
server fleets work how we move from
allocated to ready how new ones get
replaced and new players can play a game
so we can just continuously keep playing
games of droid shooter for as long as we
like because it's an amazing game
awesome back to you Sean
thank you Mark
so exciting game
we built it all from sketch and it runs
on Google Cloud
so here are some
um some links for you to
start running your games on GK autopilot
you can learn more about Google Cloud
for games check out GK autopilot
I have the link to the agonis project
and also here is a link to the global
game demo if you want to check it out
also uh we a couple of us are here from
the GK Games nxr Team here at GDC
um if you'd like to meet with us
um we have Zach and iftock here and the
audience so we'll be up at the end of
this talk at the front so come pick with
us or email us at G2x google.com
or reach out to me on LinkedIn Twitter
like to thank you so much for joining us
uh for this talk hopefully this was
exciting hopefully I was able to convey
my enthusiasm about what we are doing
for uh game workloads and hopefully got
you as excited about it as well thank
you and you can come up and ask us
questions uh or just chat with us
thank you